part flattened after a car loaded with
explosives passed through a military
checkpoint and detonated inside the
compound officials say several gunmen
then stormed the base opening fire at
soldiers before being gunned down
themselves it was around 6 o'clock there
was a very big explosion I thought there
had been an earthquake it was very
strong it's the latest in what has
become near daily assaults by the
Taliban who've been stepping up their
attacks on government facilities in
recent months undeterred by the harsh
winter this time the Taliban were able
to breach the compound security barriers
by using a vehicle they had captured
from the Afghan military some of the
injured were taken to local hospitals
for treatment more serious cases were
sent some 50 kilometers away to the
capital Kabul the government is facing
accusations that it's hiding the true
death toll so as to avoid further
worsening morale among Afghanistan's
already shattered security forces okay
let's go straight to Kabul now we're
joined by journalist Ali Latifah from
there Ali can you give us the latest on
this attack there are conflicting
reports right now on the numbers killed
and we're getting little from the
government sure so the conflicting
reports continue we don't have an
official updated number from the
government that goes beyond 40 something
so and at the basically like last night
I had been hearing several different
figures within a few hours so initially
I had heard 30 then 50 then 80 then 120
126 so this has become a major issue now
one thing we have to remember is that
this is fairly common with attacks where
people on the scene on the ground will
say that that the actual number of
killed and injured was much higher than
what is being reported
usually though that has to do with a
civilian death toll and the fact that
this was an attack on the Intelligence
Agency again that this is raises more
questions about why the real numbers are
coming out what are the exact numbers
and we also have to remember that a lot
of those that were killed were killed
obviously in the initial blast and then
also when the building collapsed in on
itself people were trapped people were
essentially they were they were killed
while being trapped you know with
falling rubble and things like that
okay Ollie what about the timing of this
attack Taliban representatives were
meeting with foreign diplomats and in
Qatar part of the u.s. initiated push
for peace talks will this attack and the
attempts to get a peace progress of
peace process going you know and
attempts to get a peace process going
because the one thing is this peace
process is still led by the United
States in the United States I've made it
very clear that they want out of this
war at any cost at this point the other
thing we do have to remember is that
this is not unfortunately uncommon in
this war we have seen you know the
government for years has been talking
about trying to get peace and talk peace
with the Taliban and they continue their
attacks on the Taliban targets and at
the same time in 2013 when the Taliban
briefly opened their office in Doha they
made a very clear statement they said
you know we will consider peace talks at
that time it didn't go anywhere but they
said we will consider peace talks and we
will keep fighting so we've been
essentially what we're seeing is a
continuation of that war where both
sides say that they want peace even
though it's become much more official at
this point from the Taliban side and yet
they both continue to attack each other
again morale with the Afghan security
forces has been shaky at best
recently how is this likely to affect
that I mean I think the morale has been
an issue for years I've done reports on
this several times you know and and the
morale comes down to many things it
comes down to feeling abandoned when you
come under attack for example when when
cities or provinces or districts are
about to fall there have been several
instances where their security forces
say they didn't get the back
and and and the help that they need it
it's as simple as you know not getting
some proper food not getting paid on
time not getting to leave on time if you
are martyred in the fight you know not
necessarily having your body delivered
to your family properly these works of
morale issues have been going on for a
long time and it comes from all sides it
comes from the fact that okay you could
be killed in this war very clearly and
it comes from the fact that you know you
while you're fighting this war you don't
feel like you're being taken care of
although the TV for us from Kabul thanks
so very much for the insights